Robert we've had a special request from
our viewers they would love to know
whether you would be up for doing any
more Nightmare on Elm Street movies and
what you would like to see happen in the
franchise from here on in well I I think
it's safe to say and and honest to say
that I've hung up my claws or I've been
declawed how each ever way you choose to
look at it no I think that when the sale
of the rights of Nightmare on Elm Street
went to Time Warner and Platinum Dunes
but the decision was made along with
their acquiring the rights to Friday the
13th Texas Chainsaw Massacre
I believe Halloween as well that they
wanted to reboot these franchises for a
new younger audience and I understand
that I'm a Hollywood kid and I know that
we remake everything and in fact of
films that our grandparents saw were all
remakes of silent films so this is
something that Hollywood has always done
there's only so many stories we have to
tell and and that's why that happens
plus it's like pulling teeth to get a
kid to see a black-and-white movie today
and when they do they enjoy them it's
not that they can't comprehend them it's
just that they sort of want to see
everything new and and loud and and fast
cut like a transformer film but I think
that the studios have been negligent in
understanding that the technology
they've been supporting for the last 10
years whether it's been video cable DVDs
blu-ray digitally remastered on-demand
you know downloads it has brought an
incredible shelf-life to various
franchises and hit movies so they I
think they've remade a lot of stuff
prematurely
that's my criticism I don't do a no
actor there's a remake we do sequels and
we do prequels I would be up perhaps for
a prequel to
The Nightmare on Elm Street I understood
there was a script floating around for a
while that John McNaughton was attached
to the wonderful director of Henry
portrait of a serial killer the michael
rooker vehicle however i I don't know if
that would ever happen now because of
the the right situation with with
Platinum Dunes and Time Warner I would
be happy to be invited to play the old
wise dream expert you know the professor
of dream analysis or Jungian dream you
know symbolism in a later reboot I
believe there was a dream expert in one
of the one of the nightmare films I
think was played by Charlie Fleischer
actually a Roger Rabbit but that would
be fun you know to be invited back as a
kind of cameo that way but that's
probably the only way you'll see me
because if they do want to reboot it
they're going to need a younger actor
which is why they chose Jackie because
Jackie can get in there they can set
Jackie on fire and and and and they can
and he's young and and and and and fit
and can still do it I can do a fight
scene once but I can't do them from 10
different angles you know it just hurts
too much for me I can't get into bed the
next day so I do my own stunts anymore
so that's probably the best answer I can
give about the future of A Nightmare on
Elm Street
with my participation at any rate if you
did a prequel what would you like to see
happen in that well one of the scripts
had a great concept which was it was I
think it was called the first kills or
something like that but as I understand
it from Gossip it had Freddy but before
he was burned and his first crimes and
he gets caught but the great role in the
in the movie are the lawyers is the
lawyer or the lawyers that get him off
because they're just these seedy corrupt
guys and they get Freddy off and it's
kind of a symbol for what's wrong with
justice in America at least with the
connivance of law and lawyers and I
thought that would be terrific you know
to see who those that's and then at the
end of course it ends with Freddy being
torched you know kind of like the tobe
Hooper pilot for Freddy's nightmares the
television series they're just one final
thing that our viewers would love to see
you do in case they don't get to see you
in a prequel or anything else it's
Freddy again they would love to hear you
do some of your favorite lines from the
movie well I'm not sure what our rating
is here but I'll start you but you can
blurt me but it's my favorite line is
the line that I came up with there was
an awkward line in dream warriors where
I thrust the girl into the television
set and I taunt her as only Freddy can
about her her designs on a career in
Hollywood but it was awkward it didn't
fit in my mouth it didn't sound like
Freddy so I came up with welcome to
prime time [ __ ]
you